اعتنت المنظمة غير الربحية ،
الغرائز البرية ، بحوالي 300
دب على مدار الـ 25 عامًا الماضية ،
وهي الآن تقوم برعاية هذه الدببة الثلاثة الصغيرة
حتى تصبح جاهزة للعودة
إلى الحياة البرية.
كانت هذه الأنثى
بالذات جزءًا من الدراسة لعدد من
السنوات وكان هناك نوع من
التعقيد ، ولسوء الحظ ،
توفيت والدب الراحل الذي ترك
وراءه ثلاثة أشبال من الدببة دون
مساعدة الغرائز البرية التي من
المرجح أن يموت منها أشبال الدب  بالطبع سوف
يموتون لأنهم غير قادرين على تدبير
أمورهم بأنفسهم في هذه المرحلة ،
وبالكاد يمكنهم المشي حتى الآن.
نحن نتواجد
كل أربع ساعات من الرضاعة ولا يتعين
علينا فعل أي شيء على
مدار الساعة في الوقت الحالي ، تزن الدببة حوالي
أربعة أرطال وتعيش في
حاضنة تقول نانيات إنهم يحاولون
التقليل إلى أدنى حد  تواصل الرجل مع الأشبال
قدر الإمكان ، لذا فإن أهم شيء هو
أنهم لا يستطيعون بصمة إذا لم تكن حريصًا
، ولأنك تعلم أننا
مقدمو الرعاية ، فإننا نعطيهم
زجاجة ، يروننا كمقدمي الرعاية في حوالي
اثنين  أسابيع سيتعلم الأشبال كيف يأكلون
الأطعمة الأخرى ، لذا ما نفعله هو أن
لدينا غرفتين مختلفتين منفصلتين
نعلمهم كيفية تناول الطعام من الطبق بمجرد أن
يكونوا أكثر تناسقًا قليلاً مع
نمو الأشبال وكذلك  العلبة
ومن ثم لدينا
حاويات خارجية كبيرة جدًا ، لذا
ننقلها من
الأصغر إلى الأكبر بينما نذهب ،
من المتوقع أن يبلغ حجم أشبال الدب حوالي 80 إلى 125
رطلاً قبل إطلاقها ، وقد تم
تعديلها جيدًا لفترة من الوقت.
عندما نطلق سراحهم ، يكون لديهم
بالفعل جميع احتياطياتهم من الدهون
في معظم الأحيان ، يكادون يتوقفون تمامًا عن الأكل
لأنهم قد
سمنوا بالفعل بما يكفي وكل ما يريدون
فعله هو الذهاب إلى النوم الشتوي ، ومن
المتوقع إطلاق الدببة  العودة إلى
البرية بعد  ينتهي موسم صيد
الدببة في أكتوبر
.